[Musique]
il est vrai que le problème est
important chaque année la consommation
de cigarettes augmente en france
résultat ce petit plaisir bien anodin
devient un véritable fléau pour la
société lorsqu'on l'analyse sur le plan
médical multiplication des cancers
multiplication des bronchites chroniques
multiplication du danger des accidents
cardiaques et en dépit de tout cela eh
bien la consommation augmente mieux elle
touche de plus en plus les jeunes l'ère
de la première cigarette allumée lors du
service militaire semble maintenant
dépassé on en est à la première
cigarette pour le résultat du bepc
c'est un fantôme hante il dans les
pièces de la première cigarette que l'on
fume par curiosité pour se donner de
l'importance ou pour imiter les adultes
tout est fait pour il n'existe aucun
tabou social vis-à-vis du tabac la
mythologie de notre temps s'appuie sur
un certain nombre de supports les
automobiles les motos les femmes
sensuelles les hommes forts etc
les publicitaires perfide utilisent ces
clichés en leur associant la cigarette
ainsi en portant à leurs lèvres ce petit
rouleau de tabac enveloppés de papier
les jeunes se valorisent s'identifient
aux vedettes du monde moderne
[Musique]
ces cigarettes en chocolat
la première incitations celle que l'on
distribuera plus tard à l'armée
fermeront la boucle
c'est ainsi que le tabac devient une
toxicomanie populaire et lucrative une
industrie florissante en france 3
milliards de paquets par an 2 kg de
tabac par habitant l'année dernière ce
commerce a rapporté 10 milliards de
francs l'état en a touché 7
mais ces petits tubes coûte quand même
cher à la collectivité
chaque année ils sont responsables de la
mort d'environ trente sept mille
personnes la plupart du temps cancers
des voies respiratoires
mais il faut aussi parler des 2 millions
de bronchite chronique et des cohortes
de vieux fumeur bien aux poumons et
souffler et au visage jaune il ya pas
écraser met alors à chaque fois je
mettais du déodorant mais mes parents ça
pour ça
les matins j'ai complètement arrêté
j'entre je pas son défilé
et pourquoi tu fumer des cigarettes
est-ce que soient les voyais des gens
fumeur je sais pas quelle société à
l'obsessionnel après je me suis dit aux
enseignants ça se tente plus nom fera
pas en voilà peut-être un de sauver mais
chaque année un million de jeunes sont
conquis par cette drogue socialement
admise le tabac la rondeur das le fait
de fumer n'est pas un besoin
physiologique normal c'est un
conditionnement social extrêmement forts
liés au mauvais exemple des adultes
éducateurs parents et cetera le projet
de loi de madame veil relatif à la lutte
contre le tabagisme
sera-t-il suffisant pour enrayer cette
épidémie on peut en douter
[Musique]